jetzt weiter hier mit dem umstrittensten
Gesetz seit langer Zeit nämlich dem
heizungsgesetz oder genauer gesagt es
heißt eigentlich Gebäude Energiegesetz
es ist abgesetzt von der Tagesordnung
jetzt ist ein Antrag der Union gestern
abend wieder aufgesetzt worden eine
Debatte also über das Gebäude
Energiegesetz auf Wunsch auch der CDU
die einen Antrag gestellt hat einen
Neustart fordert und der erstregner ist
der Parteien Fraktionschef Friedrich
Merz
frau Präsidentin meine sehr geehrten
Damen und Herren liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
Demokratie lebt vom Vertrauen in alle
staatlichen Institutionen und
Verfassungsorgane wir werden daher das
Parlament als Ort der Debatte und der
Gesetzgebung Stärke so steht es in ihrem
Koalition
meine Damen und Herren von der SPD den
Grünen und der FDP sie haben in den
letzten 18 Monaten dieses Parlament
zum einem Ort der debattenverweigerung
und zu einem Ort des durchpeitschens von
Gesetzen gemacht sie haben
sie haben nicht Vertrauen gewonnen
sondern wir alle haben als Institution
Vertrauen in Deutschland verloren
meine Damen und Herren der Kollege
Thomas Heilmann hat als Mitglied des
Deutschen Bundestages das
Bundesverfassungsgericht angerufen in
einem Organstreitverfahren und gegen die
Methode der Verabschiedung des Gebäude
Energiegesetzes erfolgreich
geklagt ich möchte zunächst dem Kollegen
Heilmann herzlich danken dafür dass er
dies getan hat er hat dies nicht getan
als Mitglied einer Oppositionsfraktion
sondern er hat dies getan als Mitglied
des Deutschen Bundestages wie sie alle
die einen Anspruch darauf haben an der
Beratung von Gesetzgebung angemessen
beteiligt und angehört zu werden das
hätte jeder von ihnen aus dem
Koalitionsfraktionen auch machen können
wir sehen Gesetzgebung die selbst bei
den
Sachverständigen zu Bemerkungen führt
wie die vom letzten Montag wo einer der
von ihnen eingeladenen Sachverständigen
im Ausschuss gesagt hat dieses Verfahren
ist für eine Demokratie unwürdig und er
hat recht meine Damen und Herren
richtig ist
das Gesetzgebung immer wieder einmal
schnell gehen muss das war in unserer
Regierungszeit so das ist in ihrer so
und manche Krise erfordert schnelle
Reaktion das hat der Deutsche Bundestag
immer wieder gezeigt dass er dies kann
aber so zu arbeiten wie sie ist in den
letzten Wochen und Monaten getan haben
hat mit Krisen jedenfalls Krisen des
Landes nichts mehr zu tun es hat
allenfalls mit koalitionskrisen zu tun
aber das ist keine Begründung für eine
solche Art der Gesetzgeber
und liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen im
jahrzehntelangen Durchschnitt der Arbeit
des Deutschen Bundestages ist etwa jedes
sechste Gesetz mit Fristverkürzung
beschlossen worden im letzten Jahr
Corona bedingt jedes zweite in diesem
Jahr ohne eine solche externe Krise
werden drei von vier Gesetzen dieser
Koalition nicht mehr mit der Einhaltung
der gesetzlich und
geschäftsordnungsmäßig vorgesehenen
Fristen beraten dies ist eine
Missachtung des Parlamentes wie sie in
dieser Dimension in der Geschichte der
Bundesrepublik Deutschland noch nicht
gegeben hat
das was sie hier tun
hat auch nicht erst in dieser Woche
bekommen sie haben die Wahlperiode
begonnen mit einer Änderung der
Sitzordnung hier im Deutschen Bundestag
erkennbar von vielen nicht allen aber
von vielen von ihnen mit dem Bemühen
diese Bundestagsfraktion in die Nähe
dieser Bundestagsfraktion zurück Rücken
so hat die Wahlperiode angefangen mit
ihnen ein Akt der Unfreundlichkeit der
sich fortgesetzt hat im Laufe der
Wahlperiode und ich gebe ihnen dass sie
dabei unruhig werden kann ich gut
verstehen aber meine Damen und Herren es
hat seine Fortsetzung
es hat seine Fortsetzung mit der
Entscheidung über das Wahlrecht
kleinere Änderungen des Wahlrechts sind
schon einmal mit einfachen Mehrheiten
hier verabschiedet worden eine solche
grundlegende Änderung des Wahlrechts mit
der Mehrheit gegen die Minderheit
durchzusetzen ist ein einmaliger Vorgang
der das Klima in diesem Hause vergiftet
hat und zwar bis zum heutigen Tag
und dann
um dann in dieser Woche die Einsetzung
eines Untersuchungsausschusses beantragt
von uns auf der Grundlage eines Quorums
dass wir sogar im Grundgesetz einmal
zugunsten einer Opposition abgesenkt
haben damit Minderheitenrechte hier im
Deutschen Bundestag wirklich geachtet
werden
einmalig in der Geschichte dieses Landes
und dieses Parlamentes lehnen sie ein
Minderheitenrecht mit fadenscheinigen
Begründungen ab und verweigern die
Einsetzung eines
Untersuchungsausschusses im Deutschen
Bundestag meine Damen und Herren
sie können ein weiteres Beispiel aus
dieser Woche nehmen
richtigerweise hat sich der Deutsche
Bundestag das Recht genommen die
Regierung hier anzuhören und zu befragen
und auch dazu den Bundeskanzler in den
Deutschen Bundestag einzuladen was wir
hier am Mittwoch erneut erlebt haben
dass der Bundeskanzler nicht eine Frage
wirklich beantwortet und stattdessen die
Fragesteller
stattdessen die Fragesteller aus unseren
Reihen darüber belehrt dass sie die
falschen Fragen gestellt haben ist ein
Ausdruck von Respektlosigkeit dem
Deutschen Bundestag gegenüber der
vollkommen
inakzeptabel ist
das Bundesverfassungsgericht hat in der
Tat in der Form entschieden aber diese
Form dient ja hat ja nicht einen
Selbstzweck sondern dient einer
sachlichen Debatte
wir werden jetzt die Gelegenheit haben
über dieses Gebäude Energiegesetz noch
einmal in allen seinen Ausprägungen zu
diskutieren und wenn sie jetzt schon
heute für die nächste Sitzungswoche des
Deutschen Bundestages dieses Gesetz in
unveränderter Form auf die Tagesordnung
im September setzen dann ist das ein
weiterer Ausdruck von Respektlosigkeit
und
Ignoranz dem Deutschen Bundestag
gegenüber dass Sie nicht bereit sind
hier den Formen zu folgen die den Zweck
haben in der Sache eine Diskussion zu
führen liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
wenn sie in dieser Sommerpause Zeit und
Neigung haben einmal zu lesen wie auch
Außenstehende unsere Demokratien
beurteilen dann nehmen sie sich das Buch
von Timothy Snyder zur Hand der schon
vor vier Jahren geschrieben hat wie
Demokratien sterben Eingriffe in das
Wahlrecht willkürliche Missachtung der
Rechte von Minderheiten ja meine Damen
und Herren die Qualität einer Demokratie
zeigt sich nicht darin ob die Mehrheit
jederzeit Ihre Rechte durchsetzt die
Qualität einer Demokratie zeigt sich ob
die Mehrheit Respekt und Achtung vor den
Rechten der Minderheit in einem
Parlament hat
und deswegen möchte ich Ihnen deswegen
möchte ich Ihnen zum Schluss
deswegen möchte ich Ihnen abschließend
sagen lassen Sie uns diese Sommerpause
die jetzt vor uns liegt nutzen
und ich bin dadurch aus auch bereit sehr
selbstkritisch unsere Rolle mit
einzubeziehen
diese Reaktion zeigt allerdings West
Geistes Kind da einige von ihnen sind
wenn ich Ihnen jetzt hier noch mal einen
Vorschlag machen möchte
möchten Sie eine Zwischenfrage oder
Zwischenbemerkungen von Frau Storch aus
der nein meine Damen und Herren ich
möchte Ihnen anbieten dass wir über die
Sommerferien einmal in aller Ruhe
darüber nachdenken wie wir gemeinsam sie
die Mehrheit der Koalitionsfraktionen
und wir die größte Oppositionsfraktion
hier im Deutschen Bundestag dazu
beitragen können dass das Vertrauen der
Bevölkerung unseres Landes in diese
Institution deutscher Bundestag wieder
gestärkt wird lassen Sie uns einen Augen
soll ich die Zwischenrufe wiederholen
die wir hier eben in der Pause aus ihren
rein gehört haben an die Adresse unserer
Fraktion soll ich das wiederholen was
wir hier eben in der Pause von ihnen
gehört haben und was zurecht ein
Ordnungsgeld ausgelöst hat können sie
nicht mal einen kurzen Augenblick den
Mund halten und mal Inhalten mit dem was
sie hier Zwischenrufen zu machen haben
meine Damen und Herren
ich mache Ihnen den Vorschlag
dass wir die vor uns liegende
sitzungsfreie Zeit nutzen einmal ihnen
zu halten und darüber nachzudenken wie
wir die Arbeit hier in diesem Parlament
zwischen der Opposition und der
Regierung aber auch zwischen ihrer
Mehrheit und der Minderheit hier im
Parlament so gestalten können dass
wieder eine Mehrheit der Bürgerinnen und
Bürger unseres Landes Vertrauen fast in
die Funktionsfähigkeit unserer
Demokratie und auch in die
Funktionsfähigkeit des Deutschen
Bundestages als dem Hort der Demokratie
unseres Landes ich finde wir sind es
unserer Demokratie und unserem Lande
schuldig nutzen wir die Gelegenheit der
Entscheidung des
Bundesverfassungsgericht genau das zu
tun herzlichen Dank
für die März kriegt jetzt ständigation
aus den eigenen rein die Union ist sauer
und das schon seit längerer Zeit hat sie
auch angesprochen beim Wahlrecht das ist
ein Vorgang der hat noch nie gegeben
ohne die Opposition wurde das Wahlrecht
einfach geändert das gehört sich nicht
hat er gesagt dann die Einsetzung des
Untersuchungsausschusses diese Woche
wurde abgelehnt das erste Mal in der
Geschichte des Deutschen Bundestages es
ist ein Minderheitenrecht und Friedrich
Merz plädierte dafür an die Mehrheit
dass sie besser mit der Minderheit
umgehen soll respektlose Süßigkeit und
Ignoranz hat er den Ampel Fraktionen
vorgeworfen hat er wurde er unmittelbar
davor auch von Herrn die offensichtlich
sehr respektlos angegangen hallo
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen jetzt mal
Ruhe hier die Kollegen müssen noch zur
Abstimmung also es ist kein Grund sich
jetzt aufzuregen und wir sollten in
dieser Debatte wir sollten in dieser
Debatte jetzt weiter fortfahren wie es
sich angemessen auch gehört und die
nächste Aufmerksamkeit schenken wir
jetzt dem Redner der SPD-Fraktion dr
Johannes Fechtner ist einer der
Parlamentarischen Geschäftsführer und
Sprecher für Wahlprüfung Immunität und
vor allen Dingen für Geschäftsordnung
des Bundestages
zu einem vertrauensvolle miteinander
hier im Parlament in dass die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger volles Vertrauen
haben können dazu gehört es aber auch
dass die Opposition bereit ist zu
Gesprächen bereit ist zu Kompromissen
und zu Gemeinsamkeiten und nehmen Sie
den Untersuchungsausschuss den sie haben
wollten wir haben ihnen mehrfach
Gespräche angeboten wir haben Ihnen die
Argumente durch sachverständlich auf den
Silbertablett serviert und ihre Reaktion
war kurz nach dem letzten Gespräch den
Antrag durchzupeitschen hier eine Ihnen
auf die Tagesordnung zu setzen also da
müssen sich mal an die eigene Nase
fassen auch die Opposition muss hier
wirklich tatsächlich Gestalt haben und
nicht nur die schnelle Schlagzeile
suchen sehr geehrter Herr Kollege
meine Damen und Herren 30 Prozent der
CO2-Emissionen in Deutschland gekommen
vom heizen und wenn wir die Pariser
Klimaschutzziele einhalten wollen dann
müssen wir mehr Tempo machen dann müssen
wir schnell näher für den Klimaschutz
tun und deswegen war es gut dass wir
dieses Gebäude Energiegesetz jetzt so
vorangetrieben haben liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen und ich will ausdrücklich
einräumen dass der ursprüngliche
Vorschlag Potenzial nach oben hatte aber
wir haben zügig und sehr grundlegend
diese Vorschläge
überarbeitet es gibt jetzt den Schutz
für die Mieterinnen und Mieter 5% pro
Quadratmeter und mal ganz sachlich auf
die Vorteile hinzuweisen die gibt es ab
sofort bis zu 70 % Förderung für die
neue Heizung auch das ein ganz großer
Fortschritt und ganz da ist auch dass
wir technologieoffen sind die Bemerkung
gestatten Sie mir als Schwarzwälder das
Holz und Pelle Teilungen auch zukünftig
eingebaut werden können auch das ist
eine ganz wichtige
wichtiger Teil in Änderungsantrag und in
der Tat wir machen Tempo beim
Klimaschutz und das ist der Punkt des
Bundesverfassungsgerichts denn was sagt
das Bundesverfassungsgericht denn ganz
konkret das Bundesverfassungsgericht hat
eben nicht festgestellt das ist ganz
wichtig dass wir abgeordnetenrechte
verletzt hätten nein des
Bundesverfassungsgericht hat gesagt es
kann nicht ausgeschlossen werden dass
unser hohes Tempo den rechten vom
Abgeordneten Heilmann zu wider laufen
könnte möglicherweise und hat deshalb
gesagt dann sollen wir lieber die
Abstimmung verschieben es hat
insbesondere nichts über den Inhalt des
Gebäude Energiegesetz gesagt da hören
wir immer wieder enteignungsvorwürfe aus
der Union das stimmt überhaupt nicht
ganz im Gegenteil das
Bundesverfassungsgericht hat uns einen
klaren weggewiesen wie wir noch im Juli
also in nächster oder übernächste Woche
dieses Gebäude Energiegesetz hätten
verabschieden können also kann überhaupt
keine Rede davon sein dass es
verfassungswidrig ist das ist
Enteignungen sind oder dass wir hier
abgeordnetenrechte
übermäßig beeinflusst hätten wohl kaum
hätte das bundesverfassungsrecht diesen
ganz konkreten handlungsvorschlag
gemacht liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
das will ich ja ausdrücklich allen sagen
die uns Verfassungswidrigkeit oder die
Verletzung von Abgeordneten rechten
vorwerfen meine sehr geehrten Damen und
Herren
und wie geht es jetzt weiter wir halten
uns an die Ausführungen des
Verfassungsgerichtes wir wollen mehr
Tempo im Klimaschutz und deswegen werden
wir gleich in der nächstmöglichen
regulären Sitzung diesen
Tagesordnungspunkt aufsetzen und werden
das Gebäude Energiegesetz verabschieden
und in der Tat damit alle Bürgerinnen
und Bürger das Handwerk die
Bauwirtschaft und alle Beteiligten
Klarheit haben danke ich ausdrücklich
den Fraktionsvorsitzenden für die ganz
klare Ansage dass dieses Gesetz so
kommen wird da haben jetzt alle Zeit
sich darauf einzustellen und das ist
glaube ich ein ganz ganz wichtiges
Zeichen dass dieses Gesetz zum ersten
ersten 2024 in Kraft treten wird liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und in der Tat der Änderungsantrag der
ist komplex andererseits wenn ich mich
erinnere was wir alles etwa zum EEG in
der großen Koalition beschlossen haben
in ähnlichen tempo da habe ich von der
großen Koalition heute und insbesondere
von der Union überhaupt nichts dazu
gehört und es ist ja glaube ich auch
bezeichnend dass nicht die
Unionsfraktion dass nicht mehrere
Unionsabgeordnete sondern dass der
Kollege Heilmann Respekt und
ausdrücklichen Dank für Ihre Vorgehen
das von dort die Initiative kam weil ich
glaube eins ist nämlich klar sie wissen
ganz genau in welcher interessanten
Diskussionen was Fristen angeht wir
jetzt hier geraten denn man darf ja
schon auch mal die Frage stellen ist es
denn wirklich so klug aus Grundgesetz
Artikeln jeweils orientiert am
Einzelfall jetzt unsere beratungsfristen
zu definieren also da sind wir sehr
gespannt wie das
Bundesverfassungsgericht in der
Hauptsache in der Hauptsache dann
entscheidende für uns ist jedenfalls
ganz klar sehr verständlich respektieren
wir die Entscheidung des
Bundesverfassungsgerichtes aber wir
sagen nicht nur dass wir sie
respektieren sondern Kollege Schnyder
habe ich schon gesagt dass wir im Herbst
an eine grundlegende Reform der
Geschäftsordnung herangehen wollen und
da werden wir uns mit der Frage
beschäftigen ob unsere Regelungen was
die Fristen die Abläufe hier angeht
präzise genug sind oder ob wir hier noch
Änderungsbedarf haben für heute wollen
wir aber nicht entscheiden wir machen
das im September meine sehr geehrten
Damen und Herren wir brauchen mehr Tempo
in Klimaschutz mehr Klarheit mehr
Rechtssicherheit und das schaffen wir in
der ersten Septemberwoche mit dem neuen
Gebäude Energiegesetz vielen Dank
Johannes Fechner hat jetzt mehrfach
gesagt die erste Septemberwoche das ist
aber die Woche wo der Haushalt gelesen
wird das ist wäre auch ungewöhnlich dort
so eingesetzte verabschieden es wird
dann wohl eher am 18 bis 22 September
stattfinden müssen
hat dann bitte jetzt
jetzt gibt's noch die Möglichkeit das zu
tun so Alexander doben sich hier noch
nicht abgestimmt er muss jetzt raus
eilen diese Abstimmung ist ja namentlich
über das LNG gesetzt
genau und alles weiter für die AFD
Fraktion hat jetzt als nächstes die hier
zu der Beschluss der
bundesgebäude Energiegesetz hier das
Wort
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren die
Entscheidung des
Bundesverfassungsgerichts hat uns die
Schande erspart das hat ignorantes
unausgegorenes und stümperhaft
zusammengeschusterte Gesetz mit der
Brechstange erzwungen wird sie wollten
dieses grüne ideologieprojekt unter
Missachtung der Sorgen der Bürger und
der Rechte des Parlaments durch
Peitschen und die begründeten Einwände
ganzer herrscheren von Fachleuten
arrogant beiseite wischen und sie haben
den Schuss offenbar noch immer nicht
gehört denn sie halten stur an diesem
Projekt fest und auch Sie von der Union
wollen das heizungsgesetz gar nicht
verhindern das haben sie ja auch gesagt
ein heizungsgesetz ist aber in zwei
Monaten noch genauso falsch wie jetzt
daran ist auch nicht zu reparieren denn
das ganze Vorhaben den Menschen
schreiben zu wollen wie Sie Ihre Wohnung
und Häuser zu heizen haben ist nicht nur
falsch es ist auch verfassungswidrig sie
reden von Respekt aber sie vergreifen
sich am privat Eigentum der Bürger
schamlos das Verfassungsrecht schützt
das privat Eigentum ihr verarmungs- und
Enteignungsgesetz zwingt private
Eigentümer ihre Rücklagen und Ressourcen
für teure ineffiziente und in vielen
Fällen untaugliche Stromheizung zu
opfern sie treiben sie in die
verschuldungsfalle viele werden ihr
Eigentum nicht halten können
internationale Investoren stehen schon
bereit für den großen Ausverkauf
Millionen Mieter werden die Zeche durch
steigende Mieten mit zahlen müssen die
Welt lacht über Deutschland
weil seine Regierung ohne Not
Volksvermögen vernichtet die
Mittelschicht ruiniert und die Industrie
aus dem Land vertreibt für die
Reduzierung von CO2-Emissionen und die
Beeinflussung des Weltklimas ist ein
heizungsgesetz komplett nutzlos
monatelang haben sie daran herum
gefuscht aber sie können noch nicht
einmal sagen wie hoch die CO2 Einsparung
überhaupt sein sollen sie lassen die
Bürger über die wahren Kosten im
Unklaren und täuschen Sie mit
subventionsversprechungen die sie nicht
zahlen können Sie sagen den Menschen
auch nicht die Wahrheit über die
weiteren Anschläge auf das Volksvermögen
die auf dem Umweg über die EU drohen
übrigens angestoßen von der
cdu-kommissionspräsidentin Ursula von
der Leyen ein verschärftes geweg der
sanierungszwang durch die bevorstehende
EU-Gebäuderichtlinie und die Einführung
des monströsen
euco2 zer tifikate Handels im Gebäude
Sektor bedrohen ganze Bevölkerung
Schichten mit
wohlstandsvernichtung und Enteignung und
hier waren sieht man einmal mehr
die Doppelstandards und die Heuchelei
der CDU ein heizungsgesetz nützt
niemandem außer internationalen
Investoren und der Wärmepumpen Lobby die
auch ohne den klarenchef reichen hier
das Wirtschaftsministerium fest im Griff
haben und es nützt den klimaideologen
die damit ihre Träume von einer
ökosozialistischen Planung
Mangelwirtschaft mit lastenfahrrädern
und Kerzen realisieren wollen in der
Vorschriften und Zwänge an die Stelle
von Privat Eigentum von Wohlstand
Vernunft und fairem Wettbewerb treten es
ist schon klar es ist völlig klar warum
sie das so hektisch erzwingen wollten
sie haben Angst vor den Bürgern vor den
eigenen Wählern denn sie begreifen sehr
gut dass sie belogen betrogen enteignet
und ärmer gemacht werden sollen ihre
Rechnung wird deshalb nicht aufgehen
vier fünf Stellen vier Fünftel der
Menschen in diesem Land sind gegen das
heizungsgesetz hier Drittel dass sie
Bruchrechnung Mathematik nicht können
das ist völlig klar lassen sie sich das
erklären was 4/5 eigentlich bedeutet es
bleibt dabei das Beste heizungsgesetz
ist kein
heizungsgesetz
nutzen Sie die Denkpause nutzen Sie die
Denkpause die ihnen das
Bundesverfassungsgericht
dankenswerterweise gegeben hat und
Stampfen Sie dieses unsägliche Gesetz
komplett ein ich bedanke mich
eine kleine Beobachtung eine meiner
Damen und Herren Christian Lindner der
Bundesfinanzminister hat den Worten von
Friedrich Merz hier im Plenum gelauscht
danach ist er gegangen und es sitzt
überhaupt kein Minister mehr auf der
Regierungsbank Robert Habeck da dachte
man vielleicht kommt er dann doch hier
noch in den plenarsa scheint auch an
dieser Debatte kein Interesse zu haben
während die Bundestagspräsidentin jetzt
noch mal nachfragt ob noch eine
abgestimmt hat er keine da ist die nicht
abgestimmte Person muss richtig
und damit werden dann die Ohren wohl
geschlossen Bündnis 90 die Grünen dr
till Steffen
Geschäftsführer der Grünen jetzt weiter
als nächster
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin meine
geschätzten Kolleginnen und Kollegen
also Frau Weidel sie haben offenbar den
Beschluss des Bundesverfassungsgerichts
überhaupt nicht gelesen überhaupt nicht
und nicht immer Ansatz sie haben mir
eine Rede gehalten die auswendig gelernt
waren ansonsten abgelesen also ich finde
ihre Aussage für Youtube die können Sie
auch in ihrem Büro aufnehmen aber das
ist keine Teilnahme an der Debatte im
Deutschen Bundestag so geht es nicht so
geht es nicht
Achtung des demokratischen Diskurses wir
müssen hier Ringen ja wir müssen hier
Ringen über richtige Lösung über den
richtigen Umgang aber was sie hier tun
ist wirklich eine Beleidigung des
Parlaments und
das Gericht hat nämlich mit keinem Wort
jetzt hören Sie mal zu sie haben es ja
nicht gelesen deswegen sage ich Ihnen
Herr Baumann sie können sich ruhig nach
vorne umdrehen das wird schon erlaubt
sein
ja echt also ich meine was ist denn das
jetzt aber wirklich sie können jetzt sie
nehmen überhaupt nicht Teil einer
Debatte weißt du über mich interessiert
sie brauchen auch keine Zwischenfrage
stellen so also das Gericht ich sag's
Ihnen jetzt noch mal das Gericht hat mit
keinem Wort das Gesetz den Gesetzentwurf
der hier vorliegt kritisiert mit keinem
Wort das mit keinem Wort gesagt da ist
das eigentumsgrundrecht berührt oder
irgendwie sowas was ihr vorgetragen
wurde es hat gesagt auf den Antrag des
Abgeordneten Heidelmann der eine Kritik
am Verfahren vorgetragen hat es hat
gesagt es kann nicht ausgeschlossen
werden dass diese Kritik zutrifft und
hat dann eine Folgenabwägung getroffen
und deswegen finde ich auch interessant
was der Antrag der cdu/cs beinhaltet
weil der ja gar nicht auch wieder nicht
zum Thema des Beschluss des Gerät
sondern er sagt das ganze Gesetz
sozusagen gemacht werden dazu hat das
Gericht gar nichts gesagt gibt es gar
keinen Anlass dazu
und deswegen finde ich interessant wie
sie jetzt hier auch aufgetreten sind und
ich finde ja auf dem Diskurs einlassen
das müssen wir wir müssen hier Ringen
ich finde die Tonalität zu sagen die
sollen Abgeordnete den Mund halten wäre
jetzt nicht der richtige Einstieg um
dahin nein ich finde dass wir hier nicht
da so miteinander umgehen sollen und ich
finde es auch interessant weil wir
durften in der Süddeutschen heute lesen
dass bis zu den Beschluss am Mittwoch
aus der Unionsfraktion zu hören war dass
seine Einzelaktion das Abgeordneten
Heilmann gewesen und zweitens finde ich
sie auch ganz interessant zweitens finde
ich auch ganz interessant dass die erste
Entscheidung wo das
Bundesverfassungsgericht gesagt hat
passt mal auf mit dem Fristen das war ja
die Entscheidung zur
Parteienfinanzierung die die groko in
der letzten Wahlperiode noch kurz vor
Schluss durchgeprügelt hat und wo die
Parteien noch sich bessere Finanzierung
sichern wollten diese Entscheidung hat
das
Bundesverfassungsgericht gemacht das war
eine Kritik an ihren Vorgehen also
sollten an der Stelle ein bisschen
abrüsten
Frage es war eine Meldung von Herrn ich
habe jetzt versucht diese Zwischenfrage
zu unterdrücken weil ich gesehen habe er
redet ja gleich noch selber aber wenn
Sie die zulassen möchten dann will ich
das nicht aufhalten
vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin und vor
allen Dingen vielen Dank Herr Dr Steffen
ich rede erst in einer halben Stunde
oder ist der Punkt ja dann auch schon
wieder vorbei
erstens vorweg nur weil ich das war
nicht der Grund meiner Zwischenfrage sie
haben natürlich völlig Recht ich habe
wieder beantragt das über den Inhalt des
Gesetzes etwas entschieden wird ich
hätte es auch gar nicht beantragen
können im organstaltverfahren und
dementsprechend das Verfassungsgericht
dazu nichts gesagt einfach mal die
Fakten offenzulegen aber wenn wir bei
den Fakten sind sie haben gerade gesagt
ich hätte keine Unterstützung der
Fraktion gehabt das ist in mehreren
Dimensionen unrichtig es ist rechtlich
und so ist die Mitteilung eines
Mitarbeiters dass der des präsidente der
CDU zu verstehen dass ich diesen Antrag
alleine gestellt habe und sie kennen uns
ja schon ein bisschen länger aber wir
davor eine vergleichbare Funktion hatten
sie wissen ganz genau dass ich sehr
lange und auch schon in der letzten
Legislaturperiode gerade die Verfahren
hier im Deutschen Bundestag auch
öffentlich angegriffen habe das gehört
auch zum zu und deswegen habe ich in
meiner ersten meine AG dann mit sehr
intensiven Gesprächen beim ersten
Parlamentarischen Geschäftsführer und
dann mit unserem Fraktionsvorsitzenden
das ausgetauscht die waren lange
informiert und insbesondere und das
Wissen hier alle Fraktionen hat die
cdu/csu-fraktion auf zehn Seiten sehr
ausführlich begründet warum mein Antrag
in der Sache richtig ist deswegen ist
die Erzählung die Sie auch einen
Journalisten immer erzählen das sei ein
Alleingang von mir schlicht unrichtig
und ich würde Sie bitten und auch fragen
ob sie das zukünftig korrekt darstellen
also vielen Dank für diese Aufklärung
und wenn sie mir das so berichten dann
werde ich dem nicht widersprechen und in
der Sache haben sie auch ein nein ganz
wenn Sie das so berichten wunderbar und
ich in der Sache haben Sie auch einen
wichtigen Punkt angesprochen und ich
danke Ihnen auch ausdrücklich dass sie
das gestern so benannt haben das ist
eine Kritik an Verfahren ist die Sie in
dieser Wahlperiode wahrgenommen haben
und diese in der letzten Wahlperiode
auch wahrgenommen haben und das sind
ganz wichtiger Punkt über den wir
sprechen müssen weil wir haben ja Herr
März hat es zitiert wir haben mehr als
Ampel gesagt wir müssen besser werden
weil wir eine Kritik an der groko an dem
Arbeit der letzten Wahlperiode
wahrgenommen haben und gesagt haben da
müssen wir besser werden wir wollen
rauskommen daraus dass im schweinskalopp
Gesetze hier durchgepeitscht werden wir
wollen dazu kommen wir wollen dazu
kommen dass wir Gesetze in Regelfall in
drei Sitzungswochen beraten erste
Sitzungswoche erste Lesung zweite
Sitzungswoche dann die Anhörung dritte
Sitzungswoche Auswertung und die der
Abschluss hier im Plenum das ist das
Ziel was wir uns gesetzt haben weil wir
gesehen haben das ist ungut für das
Parlament wenn man das verkürzt so und
ich sage ausdrücklich in vielen Fällen
haben wir das auch geschafft dass wir so
verfahren aber eben in vielen Fällen
auch nicht und das ist in der Tat
natürlich etwas worüber man sehr
gründlich Gedanken machen müssen worüber
wir reden müssen im Parlament warum das
so ist und was wir daran ändern müssen
was wir daran ändern können
und es gibt ja Gründe es gibt ja Gründe
warum Gesetze manchmal schneller gehen
müssen wir hatten das in diesem Jahr mit
der Frage der Energieversorgung und da
mussten wir schnell agieren weil wir
ansonsten kalte Wohnungen gehabt hätten
wenn wir nicht schnell umgestellt hätten
nach dem russischen Angriffskrieg es gab
solche Situationen in der letzten
Wahlperiode im Kontext der Pandemie wo
die Frage gestellt wurde geht das
überhaupt pandemiebekämpfung unter
Beteiligung des Parlaments da musste das
Parlament sich beteiligen weil wir
wollten das und die grüne
Bundestagsfraktion hat aus der
Opposition auch diese schnellen
Verfahren akzeptiert unterstützt und
konstruktiv in der Sache mitgewirkt das
ist manchmal notwendig aber wir müssen
natürlich aufpassen dass wir es auf
diese Fälle beschränken und was ehrlich
gesagt auch nicht funktionieren kann ist
eine Konfliktbewältigung den Kabinett
nicht in Aussender ausreichenderweise
erfolgt ist wir haben Gesetze die wir
hier im Deutschen Bundestag von Grund
auf entwickeln wir hatten das bei den
Gruppenverfahren wo wir über ein Jahr
beraten haben wir hatten das bei der
Wahlrechtsreform die Kommission
eingesetzt haben die ein Jahr lang
beraten hat alle Argumente hin und
schwer bewegt hat am Ende haben wir
abgeschlossen aber der Regelfall wenn
wir in diesem drei Wochen durchkommen
wollen wenn wir in diesen drei
Sitzungswochen durchkommen wollen setzt
das natürlich voraus dass ein
Gesetzentwurf der Bundesregierung
vorliegt der tatsächlich auch politisch
vollständig getragen wird und wenn dann
schon bei Kabinettsbeschluss gesagt wird
ich habe hier eine Protokollerklärung
ich glaube das muss vielleicht noch mal
geändert werden dann ist es ein
konfliktprogramm was uns in dieser
üblichen Zeit vor Schwierigkeiten führt
und zu solchen Friktionen auch führen
kann und deswegen glaube ich das ist der
wichtige Punkt wir müssen als Parlament
Selbstbewusstsein wir müssen als
Parlament Selbstbewusstsein gegenüber
der Regierung und in solchen Fragen
sicherstellen dass wir ausreichende
Beratungszeit haben und wir müssen aber
auch
wir müssen aber auch Selbstbewusstsein
gegenüber dem Bundesverfassungsgericht
als Parlament es kann nicht unser
Interesse sein das ist das
Bundesverfassungsgericht im Einzelnen
Fristen vorgibt an welcher Stelle wir
jetzt wie lange zu beraten haben wir was
wie lange lesen muss was wir erreichen
müssen ist tatsächlich dass wir in
eigener Verantwortung das hinkriegen
dass wir ein eigener Verantwortung
hinkriegen solche Fristen einzuhalten
und deswegen müssen wir das
Hauptsacheverfahren gründlich
miteinander betreiben das Auswerten der
Flächen hat es gesagt was über jetzt
erreicht haben ist wir haben ein Gesetz
vorliegen das im September beschlossen
werden kann wir haben ausreichend Zeit
für den Abgeordneten Heilmann dass er
sich dieses Gesetz zu dass er dieses
Gesetz auch anschauen kann ich bin
gespannt auf die Bilder aus der Europa
Rundreise die schönsten Wärmepumpen in
allen möglichen Staaten die können jetzt
überall angucken das ist tatsächlich
funktioniert ich freue mich drauf
vielen Dank Herr Kollege
Steffen ich und dergleichen Aussprache
kommen zurück zu Zusatzpunkt 10 und gebe
ihnen das Ergebnis der namentlichen
Schlussabstimmung wegen Gesetzentwurf
der Bundesregierung zum Entwurf eines
Gesetzesänderung Gesetzes und des
Energiewirtschaftsgesetzes des
Drucksachen 2072 79 und 20 73 65 und 20
76 22 bekannt abgegebene Stimmkarten 675
mit ja haben gestimmt 370 mit Nein haben
bestimmt
30014 damit ist der Gesetzentwurf
angenommen
dann kommen wir zurück zur Aussprache
das war jetzt das Ergebnis der
namentlichen Abstimmungen zum LNG
gesetzent der nächste Redner ist der
Fraktionsvorsitzende der Linksfraktion
Dietmar Bergisch
ja herr Präsident meine Damen und Herren
zunächst eine Bemerkung Richtung Union
machen ich finde ja vieles was sie heute
vorgelegt haben sehr vernünftig aber es
ist offensichtlich so dass man in der
Opposition so unendlich schnell lernen
kann denn ich erinnere mich noch sehr
gut in der letzten Legislaturperiode gab
es ja ähnliche Verfahren vom
Bundesverfassungsgericht wo sie
gemeinsam mit der SPD das verteidigt
haben und ich finde diese Schlussfolge
sind richtig aber es ist eben wirklich
auch etwas arrogant zu sagen naja jetzt
ist das so schlimm nein es ist seit
vielen Jahren höchst problematisch und
erst wird Zeit dass wir es verändern und
im übrigen um das auch klar zu sagen
ich finde ja Zwischenrufe kenne ich und
sie sind teilweise sehr unqualifiziert
und trotzdem geht der Satz halten Sie
den Mund nicht jeder kann hier erzählen
was er will wir sind wir sind im
deutschen Parlament lieber im März das
ist trotzdem muss man eins sagen was wir
in der letzten Woche gesehen haben war
unsere Demokratie unwürdig meine Damen
und Herren die non-charlangs mit der
hier umgegangen worden ist auch von
Regierungsmitgliedern die geht eben
nicht wir brauchen viel viel mehr
Nachdenklichkeit auch im Ergebnis des
jetzigen Verfahrens und wenn ihr eben
gesagt worden ist ja völlig richtig dass
wir Verbesserung wollten als Ampel die
Realität ist eben eine andere drei von
vier Gesetzen mit Frist Verkürzung das
kann doch nicht mehr normal sein und sie
sagt das mal für eine kleinere Fraktion
für die ist das denn so ziemlich
unmöglich all das wirklich zu
durchdringen also da müssen sie
Veränderung endlich selber in der Ampel
durchsetzen und richtig ist auch dass
wir die Geschäftsordnung reden da sind
wir in jeder Hinsicht offen denn es
bleibt
keine Komparsen die Bundesregierung hält
sich nicht die Abgeordneten es wäre
übrigens ganz gut wenn wenigstens ein
Minister bei dieser Debatte dabei wäre
das niemand dabei ist das ist auch eine
Missachtung des Parlaments meine Damen
und Herren und ich sage mal ganz klar
ich appelliere insbesondere an die
Abgeordneten der Ampel
Selbstbewusstsein entwickeln gegenüber
der Regierung das muss deutlicher werden
wir sind das Parlament wir entscheiden
und nicht die Bundesregierung meine
Damen und Herren ich will ganz klar
sagen
und Verfahren haben doch zu einem
geführt das ist unendlich viel Angst in
der Bevölkerung gibt das Vertrauen ist
das ist eine Verunsicherung gibt das
können wir doch alle nicht leugnen und
das trifft er nicht nur die Regierung
das trifft uns alle und dann müssen wir
doch mindestens mindestens nachdenklich
werden und deswegen auch ganz klar dass
jetzt das sagt der Wirtschaftsminister
ich habe zwei Tage vorher noch gehört
wird durchgesetzt muss durchgesetzt
werden sagt der Bundeskanzler sagt der
Generalsekretär der SPD und jetzt ist
kein beeindruckender können wir auch im
September machen meine Mutter so geht
das nicht wenigstens nach dem Urteil des
Verfassungsgericht müssen sie
Schlussfolgerung ziehen auch in ihrer
Kommunikation das ist das mindestens
eine Bemerkung noch zum Gebäude
Energiegesetz als solches also ehrlich
gesagt was sie da zelebriert haben mit
dem ersten Entwurf der dann zu lesen
waren in einer großen Zeitung
der völlig inakzeptabel war sie haben
viel verändert Streit ohne Ende und man
muss auch sagen Dilettantismus in der
ersten Runde ich meine die Idee dass die
kommunale wärmeplanung irgendetwas damit
zu tun haben könnte auf die hätte man
kommen können auf die hätte man wirklich
kommen können und dann für die
Brechstange angesetzt und das ist doch
das Problem und wir wissen heute nicht
eben höre ich die Folgen für die
Mieterinnen und Mieter die werden nicht
da sein hat Donnerwetter ich wusste das
gar nicht das ist ja schön dass jemand
zuhören aber wenn sie jetzt sagen wenn
sie jetzt sagen so wie das Gesetz ist
wird es verabschiedet ehrlich gesagt das
ist wieder eine Missachtung des
Verfassungsrecht es kann doch sein dass
außer Opposition sogar von uns
ausgekommen die sind voll sind sie haben
doch selbst viel Kompetenz matthias hat
vielleicht noch eine Idee wie es besser
wird und das wäre doch nicht schlecht
das ist doch nicht schlecht nicht das
ist oder stirbt das ist das falsche
herangehen und wenn Sie hier immer noch
das was soziale Ausgleich sein soll ja
auch das weiß ich bis heute nicht das
müssen wir mindestens Wissen darüber
muss gestritten werden ordentliche
Verfahren im Ausschuss und ordentliche
Verfahren hier das versuchen sie wieder
zu missachten und das geht nicht nehmen
Sie das Verfassungsgericht ernst und
gehen Sie darüber hinaus in ihrer
Nachdenklichkeit danke schön
[Applaus]
mit vielen Aspekten über die sich
sicherlich lohnt nachzudenken Fraktion
für die Liberalen hat jetzt hier
innenpolitischer Sprecher Konstantin
Kuhle das Wort in der Debatte
[Musik]
herr Präsident meine Damen und Herren
wer sich als Abgeordneter momentan auf
Reisen durch dieses Land befindet der
wird Zeuge einer großen Verunsicherung
einer Verunsicherung bis tief in die
Mitte der Gesellschaft und diese
Verunsicherung hängt zusammen mit der
Anzahl und mit der Dichte an Krisen mit
denen unser Land zu tun hat dazu gehört
insbesondere die corona-pandemie dazu
gehört der russische Angriffskrieg gegen
die Ukraine dazu gehört vieles mehr und
diese Bewegung diese Krisen haben dazu
geführt dass die Mitte der Gesellschaft
verunsichert ist und dass der
gesellschaftliche Zusammenhalt zu kippen
droht und natürlich versuchen in dieser
Zeit die Feinde der offenen Gesellschaft
und die Feinde der liberalen Demokratie
sich diese Verunsicherung zu Nutze zu
machen das dürfen wir nicht zulassen und
deswegen müssen wir selbstkritisch
feststellen dass die Verfahren die Tiere
mitunter durchgeführt worden sind nicht
gegen die Verunsicherung etwas
beigetragen haben sondern sogar zu
dieser Verunsicherung noch beigetragen
haben Liebe Kolleg
und weil das so ist bin ich auch dankbar
und glaube dass es richtig ist dass wir
die Änderungen des Gebäude
Energiegesetzes nicht in einer
Sondersitzung in der Sommerpause
durchführen sondern dass wir das mit
Bedacht in der ersten Sitzungswoche nach
der sitzungsfreien Zeit tun damit können
wir einen Beitrag dazu leisten dass mit
Bedacht und in Ruhe über die
Änderungsanträge zum Gebäude
Energiegesetz beraten werden kann und
das Gesetz dann in dieser Form
beschlossen werden kann liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen was mich aber
nachdenklich macht ist die Rede von
Friedrich Merz denn ich hätte mir von
einer Fraktion die während der
corona-pandemie die Parlamentsrechte bis
zur Unkenntlichkeit geschliffen hat doch
auch ein bisschen mehr Selbstkritik an
dieser Stelle gewünscht
und dann haben sie
und dann haben sie lieber Kollege Merz
hier ernsthaft gesagt
dass diese Bundesregierung und diese
Parlamentsmehrheit es nicht mit einer
externen Krise zu tun hätte ich weiß
nicht ob die ökonomischen Auswirkungen
des Krieges gegen die Ukraine bei Ihnen
persönlich angekommen sind aber es gibt
sehr viele Menschen in Deutschland die
machen sich große Sorgen um die Zukunft
dieser Volkswirtschaft die machen sich
Sorgen um die Lebenshaltungskosten die
machen sich Sorgen um die Inflation die
machen sich Sorgen darum ob es in
Zukunft in diesem Land überhaupt noch
eine Industrie gibt die machen sich
Sorgen weil wir die größte
migrationskrise in Europa seit dem
Zweiten Weltkrieg haben und angesichts
dieser Krisen davon zu sprechen dass
diese Parlaments Mehrheit keine externe
Krise zu bewältigen hätte ist wirklich
ein starkes Stück das mögen die
Wählerinnen und Wähler bitte bewerten
dass das mit der Wahrnehmung der
Realität zu tun hat
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir sind
dafür verantwortlich alle miteinander
diese Krisen in unserem Land vernünftig
zu bearbeiten und zu bewältigen die
Verunsicherung in der Mitte der
Gesellschaft hat aber auch etwas damit
zu tun dass viele Menschen das Gefühl
haben dass die Politik eigentlich nichts
anderes mehr Macht als Krisen
Bewältigung das war ja auch die übliche
Vorgehensweise früherer Bundesregierung
und dabei ist ein hohes Maß an
zukunftsherausforderungen unter den
Tisch gefallen die Alterung der
Gesellschaft die Digitalisierung die
Frage der Bewältigung des Klimawandels
und weil die Bewältigung des
Klimawandels für diese Bundesregierung
und für diese Parlamentsmehrheit auch
ein dringliches Anliegen und ein
wichtiges Anliegen und eine wichtige
Zukunft Herausforderung ist ist es
wichtig und richtig dieses Gebäude
Energiegesetz zügig zu beschließen
und liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
es hat auch etwas mit unserer eigenen
Verantwortung zu tun ob wir unsere
Aufgabe bloß darin sehen auf externe
Krisen zu reagieren oder ob wir selber
auch gestalten wollen und wer bei einer
Bundestagswahl antritt wer die
Verantwortung übernimmt für die
Regierung in diesem Land der darf sich
nicht nur mit den Krisen beschäftigen
sondern der muss sich auch mit wichtigen
Zukunfts Herausforderungen beschäftigen
das wird diese Parlamentsmehrheit tun
und ich kann uns allen sehr raten in der
Sommerpause ein bisschen Zeit in
Gesprächen mit den Bürgerinnen und
Bürgern zu verbringen um mal ein
bisschen rauszufinden wie die Art und
Weise wie die Art und Weise wie wir so
arbeiten und wie wir hier so wirken
eigentlich bei den Menschen da draußen
ankommt herzlichen Dank
als nächster Trainer das Wort der
Kollege Alexander Dobrindt cducci
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident wer die
Kolleginnen und Kollegen Herr Fechner in
der Tat ist es so dass das
Verfassungsgericht nicht über den Inhalt
des heilsgesetz ein Urteil gefällt hat
aber es hat ein Urteil gefällt über den
Politikstil der Ampel es sei denn Urteil
Gebilde die Arroganz der Ampel darüber
hat Urteil gefällt
so und dieses Urteil ist natürlich auch
eine Aufforderung inhaltlich wieder zu
beraten ja es hat das Verfassungsgericht
hat reingeschrieben es braucht
Beratungszeit an dieser Stelle aber wenn
es eine Beratung gibt dann muss es doch
auch ein Ergebnis einer Beratung geben
aber wenn die Ampel jetzt zum September
schon genau dieses Gesetz im Parlament
unverändert wieder aufsetzt dann ist es
keine Beratung mit einem Ergebnis
sondern Missachtung des
Verfassungsgerichtsurteils genau das ist
an dieser Stelle
[Applaus]
von des Kollegen
aber es verlängert verlängert ihre
Redezeit der Kollege wahrscheinlich eine
neue Erkenntnis
sie haben jetzt hier mehrfach gesagt das
Verfassungsgericht habe einen Urteil
gefällt und ich will jetzt nicht
kleinteilig sagen indem ich sie sage es
war kein Urteil sondern ein Beschluss
aber vielleicht liegt genau daran ja
doch
ja das ist nämlich der Witz sein der
Geschichte das ist nämlich der Witz an
der Geschichte und vielleicht haben sie
das nicht mitgekriegt was der
Unterschied ist in der Sache weil
nämlich weil nämlich in diesem
Eilverfahren anders als sie behauptet
haben das Bundesverfassungsgericht ja
gar nicht gesagt hat es war zu bewegen
zu wenig Beratungszeit das hat es nicht
gesagt es war nämlich ein einfacher
fahren und diesen Eilverfahren hat es
wirklich gesagt der Abgeordnete Heimat
trägt vor es sei zu wenig Beratungszeit
und ob das so ist kann das
Bundesverfassungsgericht gar nicht
feststellen und deswegen hat das eine
Folgenabwägung vorgenommen und gesagt
was ist jetzt schlimmer das
möglicherweise die Beratungszeit zu kurz
ist oder dass etwas später dieses Gesetz
beschlossen wird nichts anderes steht in
diesem Beschluss darauf möchte ich Sie
hinweisen damit Ihre weiteren
Ausführungen auf einer zutreffenden
Tatsachengrundlage
sehr geehrte Kollege Steffen sie haben
vorhin gesagt man hätte jetzt die Chance
sich das Gesetz anzuschauen es geht
nicht um anschauen es geht um beraten
und ich kann ihn mal zitieren aus dem
Beschluss des Verfassungsgericht
wörtlich den Abgeordneten steht nicht
nur das Recht so im Deutschen Bundestag
abzustimmen sondern auch das Recht zu
beraten und das Missachten Sie hier in
dieser Stelle
und dabei geht es gar nicht nur um die
Rechte eines einzelnen Abgeordneten ich
weiß nicht warum sie dieses
Missverständnis jetzt auch wieder
vorgetragen haben es geht um die Rechte
eines jeden Abgeordneten in diesem
Parlament und nicht nur um Herrn
Heilmann
oppositionskollegen und natürlich auch
Kollegen der Ampel die das Recht haben
darüber jetzt zu beraten und ich sage
Ihnen nicht nur wir haben einen Anspruch
auch auf die Beratung auch die
Öffentlichkeit hat einen Anspruch auf
Beratung wenn Sie die Beratung hier
verengen und nicht zulassen schließen
Sie die Öffentlichkeit aus der Beratung
und das ist ein schwerer
sie reden hier ja auch ständig darüber
dass es Protest gibt in der Bevölkerung
ja explizit zu diesem heizgesetz es gibt
Misstrauen es gibt Unverständnis ja
dafür tragen sie an dieser Stelle auch
die Verantwortung weil sie die Beratung
nicht ordentlich zulassen und ich habe
mal ein paar Zitate ein paar Zitate für
Sie rausgesucht wörtlich Gründlichkeit
geht vor Schnelligkeit es war falsch den
Grünen hier auf den Leim zu gehen Frank
Scheffler FDP herzlichen Glückwunsch zu
dieser Erkenntnis nächstes Zitat
verdiente Quittung für die Grünen die in
dieses Verfahren einen unerklärlichen
Druck hineingebracht haben der
Abgeordnete Wolfgang Kopie herzlichen
Glückwunsch zu dieser Erkenntnis aber
was folgt denn jetzt daraus Herr Kollege
Kohle von der FDP was folgt jetzt aus
dieser Erkenntnis sie haben jetzt auch
deutlich gemacht es wird im September
der gleiche Entwurf beraten wir heute
hätte beraten werden soll ihre FDP hat
gestern zugestimmt ihre Fraktion hat
zugestimmt dass es keine Beratung gibt
sondern dass diese Gesetze nur ohne neue
Beratung im September so auf den
Tagesordnungspunkt
und das beschreibt den Umgang der hier
herrscht gegenüber den Parlament und
gegenüber der Öffentlichkeit und dass
das jetzt in dieser Sitzungswoche in der
letzten Sitzungswoche des Parlaments vor
der Sommerpause gleich mehrfach
stattfindet diese Missachtung die die
wir schon bei der regierungsbefragung
erkannt haben keine einzige Antwort auf
die Fragen von unseren Abgeordneten
durch den Bundeskanzler das war keine
regierungsbefragung das war
regierungsverweigerung was wir an dieser
Stelle festgestellt haben und ich sage
Ihnen die Kollegin Julia Klöckner die
hat in ihrer Fragestellung den
Bundeskanzler schlichtweg danach gefragt
was er gedenkt zu tun gegen steigende
Arbeitslosigkeit steigende Inflation
steigende Sozialausgaben und was war die
Antwort der Bundeskanzler hat gesagt er
hätte jetzt keine Zeit diese Liste der
nicht richtigen Behauptungen zu
widerlegen dass keine Antwort das
Realitätsverweigerung was hier
stattfindet in diesem Parlament die
Kolleginnen seine Zwischenfrage vom
Storch
und das ist symptomatisch das ist
symptomatisch für die Arbeit wie wir sie
in den vergangenen Monaten mit ihnen
erleben und das nicht unsere einsame
Wahrnehmung die wir da haben ich habe
noch ein paar Zitate für sie eine
überfällige Klatsche für die Ampel die
Süddeutsche Zeitung eine Ohrfeige um die
die Ampel gerade zu gebettelt hat der
Tagesspiegel die Koalition muss ihre
überheblichen Habitus Ablegen der Stern
ich kann so beliebig weiter zitieren das
ist eine Klatsche für die Ampelkoalition
die sich mit ständigen Frist
Verkürzungen und der Ablehnung des
Warburg Untersuchungsausschusses über
die Geflogenheiten des Parlamentarismus
hinwegsetzt redaktionswert Deutschland
meine Damen und Herren wenn sie nicht
daraus endlich mal lernen dass die
Wahrnehmung in der Öffentlichkeit
inzwischen die ist dass sie die Rechte
des Parlamentes und der Öffentlichkeit
vollkommen bis achten dann werden sie
weiter Verantwortung dafür tragen dass
der Protest in Deutschland entsteht und
keine Befriedung in diesem Land
eintrifft
vielen Dank Herr Kollege Lübben Frau
Kollegin ich kann eine Zwischenfrage
nicht mehr zulassene Ablauf der Redezeit
das ist das Problem ja die Fraktion hat
um eine Kurzintervention für die
Kollegin von Storch gebeten ich lasse
die kurz in der Version zu Frau von
Stolz sie haben ja vielen Dank Herr
Präsident Herr Dobrindt und auch Herr
Merz ich finde sie haben beide etwas
sehr Wichtiges gesagt dass nämlich hier
die Rechte der Abgeordneten beschnitten
werden wenn hier Fragen nicht
beantwortet werden vom Kanzler oder eben
die beratungsfristen abgekürzt werden so
dass wir unseren Rechten nicht
nachkommen können sie haben das in
extens so ausgearbeitet und wir stimmen
ihnen zu das ist alles richtig aber sich
hier als Demokraten aufzuspielen an
ihrer Seite wären sie gleichzeitig mit
ebenso unsere demokratischen Rechte
jedes Mal wieder beschneiden indem sie
uns nicht einen
bundestagsvizepräsidenten zu billigen
oder Position in Gremien zu belegen und
dann genauso sich verhalten wie die
anderen finde ich macht ihre Angriffe
einfach lächerlich weil sie auch die
demokratischen Rechte von uns mit Füßen
treten und das schon durch die gesamte
Legislatur und auch in der letzten schon
[Applaus]
sie können Antworten euch wird darauf
hinweisen es geht ums Gebäude
Energiegesetz es geht nicht um die Frage
wie man miteinander umgeht aber bitte
sie können gerne Antworten der
Kolleginnen
sehr geehrte Kolleginnen
wissen Sie was ich Ihnen an dieser
Stelle antworte ich habe in meiner
Schlussbemerkung darauf hingewiesen dass
wir in diesem Land Befriedung brauchen
und den Protest nicht weiter schüren
dürfen werde ich dieser Rede von Frau
Weidel zugehört habe hier im Parlament
da kann ich nur feststellen das was sie
veranstalten ist den Protest
weiterführen die Unzufriedenheit
weiterführen und dieses Land weiter in
eine Krise zu reiten das ist das was sie
tun und nicht das Gegenteil meine Damen
und Herren
so die nächste Rednerin ist die Kollegin
Dr Nina Scheer SPD-Fraktion
[Applaus]
Präsident liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
ich möchte noch mal eine Einordnung
vornehmen da dies leider teilweise
komplett durcheinander geht wann denn
eigentlich was hier beraten würden der
natürlich haben wir alle Respekt und das
gehört sich auch gehört sich auch so vor
der vor einem Beschluss des
Bundesverfassungsgerichts die auch schon
ausgeführt wurde ist dieser Beschluss
eine formelle eine formelle
Beschlussfassung und keine Äußerung zur
Sache die Sachentscheidung folgt noch es
ist jetzt eine formale Entscheidung
damit keine rechtsverwirkung Eintritt
denn es wurde vom
Bundesverfassungsgericht festgehalten
dass keine offenkundige und
zulässigkeiten keine offenkundige
Unbegründetheit da liegt aber damit ist
offen ob es denn begründet und zulässig
ist in der Sache insofern muss das auch
noch geprüft werden dass hier aber
gerade stattfindet ist eine
Unterstellung dass die Vortrag von dem
Kollegen Heilmann in der Sache begründet
seid das ist nicht der Fall das dürfen
wir insofern auch nicht einfach
unterstellen da das das Verfahren und
auch den Inhalt des Verfahrens aus die
Befassung mit dem Gebäude Energiegesetz
wie wir dies parlamentarisch vorgenommen
haben völlig in das falsche Licht drückt
insofern im richtigen Licht gesehen so
wie es auch tatsächlich im
parlamentarischen Verfahren
stattgefunden hat ist es wie folgt dass
die Einbringung des Gesetzentwurfes der
Bundesregierung Mitte Juno erfolgte
Mitte Juno in der Tat das ist auch kein
Geheimnis deswegen möchte ich das
durchaus noch mal erwähnen hätten sowohl
SPD-Bundestagsfraktion als auch grüne
Fraktion eine frühere Einbringung
gewünscht in der Tat hatten wir darüber
auch eine einen Essenz den wir dann
Gehalt haben in der Koalition über den
Zeitpunkt der Einbringung wir haben den
Gehalt und sind damit mit juni in ein
Verfahren Einzel getreten was für sich
genommen immer noch ausreichend
Beratungszeit und diese fest deswegen
möchte ich hier noch mal treffen dass
diese Beratungszeit gegeben war denn wir
haben eine Einbringung wie gesagt Mitte
Juni gehabt wir hatten eine erste
Anhörung schon am 21 juni wir haben uns
dann weil es umfangreiche Änderungen
geben sollte und weil es der Wunsch der
Opposition war wir wollten den Wunsch
nichts entgegensetzen deswegen haben wir
uns auch Wunsch der Opposition auf eine
zweite Anhörung verständigt wir haben es
aber nicht verfahrenstechnisch für
erforderlich gehalten eine zweite
Anhörung zu machen nein das haben wir
nicht und ich kann ihnen auch das
sachlich darlegen warum ist dieser
zweiten Anhörung nicht bedürft hätte
denn wir haben uns
aufgrund der schon gerade erwähnten
verständigungsschwierigkeit die wir zu
Beginn hatten in der Koalition auf eine
Einbringung inklusive Verständigung auf
Leitplanken geeinigt das war also die
Einbringung des Gesetzentwurfes plus
Leitplanken das heißt also wir haben uns
schon auf bestimmte Änderungen die wir
im parlamentarischen Verfahren vornehmen
würden schon vorweg geeinigt das wäre
nicht notwendig gewesen für das
parlamentarische Verfahren aber wir
haben es koalitionsintern schon getan
und da wir das getan haben und das auch
öffentlich war diese Leitplanken
öffentlich waren diese Verständigung
über die Änderung schon öffentlich war
deswegen hat auch die haben auch die
Sachverständigen die Möglichkeit gehabt
auch schon darauf Bezug zu leben
insofern hat er auch schon Gegenstand
der ersten Anhörung war auch schon
Gegenstand der ersten Anhörung eine
intensive Befassung mit diesen
Änderungen die wir dann parlamentarisch
verzogen haben insofern hatten wir im
Grunde genommen aus dieser Situation
heraus die wir uns alle jetzt so auch
nicht ausgedacht haben aber sie sie
hatte auch was außergewöhnliches aber
aus der Situation heraus hatten wir
sogar parlamentarisch betrachtet und
nicht mir ist wichtig als
Parlamentarierin das mal zu betonen
parlamentarisch betrachtet hatten wir
dadurch sogar eine Mehrwert weil wir mit
den leitplatten schon vorweg den
Sachverständigen sagen konnten hier das
wird im Mittelpunkt unserer
parlamentarischen Beratung stehen das
war ein Mehrwert das ist auch mal
wichtig das zu sagen weil wir nämlich
weil wir
das ist insofern wichtig zu betonen weil
wir nämlich mit diesen Veränderungen die
wir vorgenommen haben im
parlamentarischen Prozess sehr wohl ja
weitreichend Veränderung gemacht haben
weitreichen aber niemand anders und wenn
ihr schon wieder so komische Bemerkungen
kommen niemand anders als das Parlament
niemand anders als das Parlament hat das
Recht parlamentarisch also
Gesetzesänderungen vorzunehmen und die
gesetzlich ist das Parlament und es gibt
auch keine weitere Instanz und auch kein
Verfassungsgericht was uns die Tiefe der
Änderungen vorschreiben könnte das ist
die Hoheit des Parlaments
und deswegen ist es auch noch mal
wichtig festzuhalten ganz unabhängig
davon wie umfangreich dieser
Änderungsantrag ist den wir am 30 Juno
versendet haben und damit früher als
manche andere Änderungsanträge rumgehen
ja wir wollen das auch alle immer gerne
möglichst früh das ist auch aber das hat
auch Herr Heimann schon gesagt das ist
keine Besonderheit in dieser Koalition
und in dieser legislaturperio das ist
leider so das ist sehr häufig das war
auch in den vorangegangen
legislaturperio und so dass manchmal
Änderungsanträge sehr kurzfristig vor
der Ausschusssitzung kommen das war in
den anderen legislaturierung nicht
anders aber ich will gar nicht verabrede
stellen dass wir uns immer bemühen soll
das möglichst früh zu machen um auch die
Beteiligung bereit zu halten aber auch
Herr heimmann hatte ja zu gestanden dass
das auch in anderen Legislatur werden
auch nicht anders war ja also insofern
die Änderungen die wir am 30 Juni die
hier die Änderung der Änderungsantrag
den wir am 30 Juni vorgelegt haben der
hatte sehr umfangreiche Änderungen aber
es war trotzdem ein änder Antrag und sie
versuchen hier die ganze Zeit nein nein
nein sie versuchen hier die ganze Zeit
den Anschein zu erwecken und das ist
auch in Richtung
Bundesverfassungsgericht noch mal
wichtig festzustellen sie versuchen die
ganze Zeit den fälschlichen Anschein zu
erwecken als ob dieser Änderungsantrag
den wir am 30.06 herumgesendet haben als
ob das quasi ein neuer Gesetzentwurf
gewesen sei als ob wir den alten ersetzt
hätten durch einen neuen das ist falsch
es ist
eine Zwischenfrage aus der CDU-Fraktion
einmal sie reden ja noch weil der
Kollege hinter ihnen der darf jetzt mal
fragen
ja ich habe jetzt ganz intensiv zugehört
ihren Ausführungen und jetzt stellt sich
mir die Frage zum einen hat ja die
Koalition selbst gesagt es handelt sich
jetzt um ein neues Gesetz nachdem die
Leitplanken Vorlagen das ist der erste
Punkt und der zweite Punkt man könnte
jetzt meinen sie haben alles richtig
gemacht in dem Gesetzgebungsverfahren
also meine Frage haben sie jetzt
wirklich alles richtig gemacht bei
diesem Gesetz geben Verfahren auch an
Betracht des Beschlusses des
Bundesverfassungsgerichts
ich weiß nicht warum sie sich als
Parlamentarier selbst so klein machen
was heißt hier richtig falsch gemacht
nein was heißt hier so richtig und
falsch gemacht ist es wichtig dass wir
Verfahrensregeln einhalten und das
wichtig dass wir die Rechte der
einzelnen Abgeordneten natürlich waren
das ist das ist eine Frage die der
Selbstverpflichtung als als
Verfassungsorgan dass wir als
Gesetzgeber auch sind natürlich gilt
müssen wir auch die Rechte der
Abgeordneten waren aber es steht für das
habe ich ja gerade erläutern wollen dass
die Verfahren die wir gewählt haben das
erfahren dass Sie gewählt haben eben
kein Eingriff darstellt da unsere
Überzeugung weil es eben kein neues
Gesetz war was vorgelegt haben sondern
ein Änderungsantrag ein sehr
umfangreicher bestätigt alleine den
parlamentfrei ich wiederhole noch mal
ist hier steht alleine den Parlament
Freitag darüber zu entscheiden was in
einem Änderungsantrag steht und ich
glaube auch nicht dass es im in Ihrem
Interesse oder im Interesse von Herrn
Heilmann oder in der Diktion seines
Antrags wäre zu unterstellen dass die
Tiefe eines Änderungsantrages von einer
dritten Instanz nämlich Gericht zu
entscheiden wäre weil dann hätten wir
den Bruch der Gewaltenteilung
[Applaus]
dem Bericht dass ein Gericht darüber
entscheidet
[Applaus]
ich darf fünf Seiten umfassen dann ist
es doch ein Änderungsantrag aber wenn er
zehn Seiten umfasst dann ist es neues
Gesetz das kann es nicht sein in der
Sache deswegen betone ich noch mal
dieser Änderungsantrag ist ein
Änderungsantrag und es ist kein neuer
Gesetzentwurf und wenn sie Äußerungen
aufschnappen es ist ja auch in der in
dem Schriftart von Herrn Heilmann sind
ja auch diverse Äußerungen Zitate aus
dem Parlament herausgegriffen dann sind
die sehr verkürzt es gibt im
parlamentarischen Raum auch politische
Äußerungen wie zum Beispiel der Verweis
von der Kollegin Conrad auf die
Formulierungshilfen die aus dem
Ministerien kommen das war offenkundig
als ein Verweis auf Formulierungshilfen
verstanden worden also das war so
intendiert das bekommt man eindeutig dem
Zusammenhang entnehmen aber sie haben
daraus gemacht dass angeblich die
Bundesregierung Herr des Verfahrens der
Änderungsanträge war das ist einfach
falsch das ist falsch interpretiert und
sie wissen dass das Parlamentarier dass
die Kollegen Konrad das so nicht gemeint
hat
insofern war das eigentlich alles noch
eine erwartete Antwort auf Herrn Lenz
meine Redezeit ist trotzdem weiter
gelaufen ich habe aber hier noch
letztendlich eigentlich nur noch
hinzuzufügen dass wir intensive
Änderungen vorgenommen haben im Sinne
das Änderungsantrags zu Gunsten des
Mieterschutzes zur Gunsten einer
vorangezogenen kommunalen wärmeplanung
das war immer wichtig als SPD-Fraktion
wir haben die erweiterte Erneuerbaren
energienaktion mit hineingeholt und
viele weitere wichtige Änderungen in
diesem Sinne ist es sachlich gesehen
Herr Präsidentin eingeschlafen
vielen Dank
Nina die Sprecherin für Klimaschutz und
in Energie der SPD-Fraktion und hat hier
dann doch noch während der Rede versucht
ihre Redezeit zu verlängern für die
afd-fraktion spricht nun mag Bernhard
herr Präsident meine Damen und Herren
das ist Bundesverfassungsgericht den
heizungshammer gestoppt hat kann für sie
von der Ampel nicht wirklich eine
Überraschung gewesen sein was sie hier
bei einem Gesetz veranstaltet haben dass
die Existenz und die Altersvorsorge von
80% der Menschen in unserem Land bedroht
zeugt von bürgerverachtende Arroganz und
unbeschreiblicher
Ignoranz
und das alles nur um dieses Gesetz um
jeden Preis noch vor der Sommerpause
durchzupeitschen und zwar nicht weil es
ihnen um das Wohl der Menschen geht
sondern einzig und allein aus Angst vor
den anstehenden Landtagswahlen in Hessen
und Bayern
mit ihrem Gesetzentwurf versuchen sie
die Menschen seit Tagen zu täuschen die
Unsicherheit beim heizungsgesetz sei
angeblich Weg der Hammer kommt ja erst
wenn die kommunale wärmeplanung
abgeschlossen ist alles wird angeblich
gut die Wahrheit ist jetzt übertragen
sie das Risiko die Recht auf die Bürger
ab nächsten Jahr kann man zwar wieder
fast jede Heizung einbauen aber nur bis
die kommunale wärmeplanung vorliegt beim
Einbau wissen die Menschen also noch
nicht ob Ihre Heizung später zur
wärmeplanung passen wird oder wieder
raus muss aber ist doch gerade die
Aufgabe der Regierung dafür zu sorgen
dass zuerst eine verlässliche
wärmeplanung vorliegt auf die sich die
Bürger verlassen können und auf deren
Grundlage sie eigenverantwortlich und
sicher eine Heizung einbauen können
was sie hier aber machen ist gesamte
Risiko auf die Bürger zu verlagern indem
sie sie zwingen eine Heizung einzubauen
die wahrscheinlich dann wenige Jahre
später wieder rausgerissen werden muss
weil die kommunale wärmeplanung die
ausgewählte Heizung eben dann doch nicht
zulässt nur mit dem
hunderttausend Euro
wärmepumpensanierungsmonster können die
Menschen einigermaßen sicher sein dass
Ihre Heizung nicht wieder rausreißen
müssen aber wer hat den hunderttausend
Euro um sich davon Heizung zu kaufen ihr
heizungskammer kostet laut ihnen da
brauchen Sie gar nicht so laut
schreiender Lokal FDP hat ausgerechnet
dass er
2500 Milliarden Euro kostet also 30.000
€ pro Kopf der Bevölkerung nichts
anderes als eine absolute soziale
Katastrophe
das ist die Mieten weiter explodieren
und ist die faktische Enteignung von
Millionen von Menschen die sich ihre
eigenen vier Wände ihre Altersvorsorge
vom Mund abgespart haben diese Regierung
schickt mit dem heizungskammer Millionen
Bürger in die Armut und deshalb
heizungsgesetz muss nicht neu gestartet
werden nein Hermes es muss sofort und
entgültig gestoppt werden
die afd-fraktion mit ihrer
grundsätzlichen Kritik an dem
Gesetzesvorhaben zum gebäudeenergie
gesetzt das ja nun erst nach der
sommerpausehilfe verabschiedet wird
Julia Verlinden spricht als nächstes für
Bündnis 90 die Grünen im Deutschen
Bundestag ich glaube Sie sollten mal mit
einem Handwerker oder eine Handwerkerin
sprechen
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident
sehr geehrte Damen und Herren mein
Vorredner wollte ich noch kurz zurufen
dass Sie doch mal ein Handwerker oder
eine Handwerkerin Fragen sollten was
eine Heizung kostet jedenfalls nicht die
Summen die sie hier aufgerufen haben
sehr schade sehr schade dass das hier so
eine Fakten befreite Debatte von ihnen
war
ich möchte
ich möchte einmal zurückblicken ins
letzte Jahr
da standen wir bei einem Wert von 85
Prozent der fossil
betriebenen Heizung ja das wird nicht
besser wenn Sie das jetzt weiter
erzählen ich werde jetzt auf meine
Punkte eingehen genau also im letzten
Jahr stand ja an einem Punkt der waren
85 Prozent der Heizung Fossil betrieben
worden und das war zu einem großen
Problem geworden wenn sie sich richtig
erinnern wo wir vor ungefähr einem Jahr
standen oder auch noch vor einem halben
Jahr standen Deutschland waren nämlich
extrem abhängig gemacht worden von
fossilen Rohstoff Importen und deswegen
haben sich viele Menschen im letzten
Herbst ernsthaft gefragt ob im Winter
die Wohnungen warm bleiben würde würden
denn es gab große Sorgen davor dass wir
möglicherweise in eine gasmangelage
rutschen könnten das Gas knapp werden
könnte weil wir nicht wussten ob wir die
ausreichenden Mengen zur Verfügung
hätten weil wie gesagt die
Vorgängerregierungen Deutschland massiv
abhängig gemacht hatten insbesondere von
einem Exporteur und deswegen sind die
Preise explodiert deswegen hatten wir
eine
gaspreiskommission gegründet und diese
und das Parlament hier hatte entschieden
dass 200 Milliarden Euro zur Verfügung
gestellt werden müssen 200 Milliarden
Euro um zu unterstützen dass Menschen
nicht im Kalten sitzen dass alle sich
weiterhin das Heizen leisten können und
zwar nicht nur private Bürgerinnen und
Bürger sondern eben auch die Unternehmen
die vom Gas und vom Öl abhängig waren
diese 200 Milliarden Euro waren nicht
aus der Portokasse diese 200 Milliarden
Euro waren eine Notlösung weil
Deutschland in einer Situation war die
aufgrund der Entscheidung der Vorgänger
Regierungen und selbstverständlich durch
den brutalen Angriffskrieg von Putin auf
die Ukraine verursacht worden waren und
[Musik]
wir haben uns vorgenommen
statt künftig wieder in so einer
Situation zu sein lieber Geld zu
investieren in zukunftsfähige
Investitionen in Heizungen die uns
absichern vor solchen Abhängigkeiten und
deswegen war ein zweiter Punkt das uns
wichtig war dass wir ein Drittel der
CO2-Emission von Deutschland die
innerhalb der spätestens nächsten 22
Jahre reduziert werden müssen und die
angesichts der sehr langen
Investitionszyklen für Heizungen extrem
knapp sind also wenn wir bis zum Jahr
2045 klimaneutral sein wollen in
Deutschland dann bleibt nicht mehr allzu
viel Zeit und vor allen Dingen macht es
dann ein rechnerisch jetzt keinen Sinn
mehr noch fossile Heizung einzubauen es
ist man sieht also es war eine täglicher
ein erheblicher Handlungsbedarf und er
war dringend weil eben diese Situation
dringend abgestellt werden musste und
wir dafür sorgen wollten dass wir
zukunftsfest werden mit genau diesem
Thema der Wärme
die Union hätte in dieser Debatte die
wir spätestens seit Anfang des Jahres
über das heizungsgesetz führen auch
konstruktive Beiträge leisten können
stattdessen waren sie sehr sehr
populistisch unterwegs sie haben die
Menschen verunsichert mit ihren
Beiträgen und ich unterstütze das völlig
ich unterstütze das völlig das
Abgeordnete Verantwortung haben sich
sorgfältig
zu beraten und das Abgeordnete auch die
Verantwortung haben sorgfältig
Entscheidungen zu treffen da bin ich
völlig bei ihnen aber ich hatte in den
letzten Monaten sehr sehr oft das Gefühl
dass diejenigen von Ihnen schon lange
eine Meinung hatten bevor sie das Gesetz
den Gesetzentwurf überhaupt gelesen
hatte und das kann nicht zu einem
sinnvollen Verfahren beitragen
die Idee übrigens die Idee das Heizungen
die sowieso ausgetauscht werden müssen
die defekt sind nicht mehr repariert
werden können und die sowieso
ausgetauscht werden müssen dass die
einen Mindestanteil ein Mindestanteil
von erneuerbaren Energien vorzuhalten
haben das ist übrigens eine Idee die ist
schon 15 Jahre alt diese Idee kommt
nämlich aus Baden-Württemberg und muss
zugegebenerweise damals war das eine
Idee von einer CDU Ministerin
diese Idee haben wir als Ampel
weiterentwickelt diese Idee haben wir in
einem Gesetz diskutiert und es war
mitnichten eine Fristverkürzung in
diesem parlamentarischen Verfahren Nina
Scheers ausführlich darauf eingegangen
wir hatten vier Wochen über in denen wir
über dieses Gesetz beraten haben hier im
Parlament bisher davon waren es drei
Sitzungswochen und das ist bei sehr
vielen anderen Gesetzen die Regeln die
Beschlussempfehlung des zuständigen
Fachausschusses ist jetzt am vergangenen
Mittwoch also vorgestern ergangen und
genau das schafft auch
Planungssicherheit und Verlässlichkeit
weil Menschen und Unternehmen wissen und
sich darauf verlassen können was wir im
September hier im Bundestag beschließen
werden wir folgen nämlich der
Beschlussempfehlung des zuständigen
Fachausschusses und machen damit klar
was alles auf die Menschen zukommt was
passieren wird ab dem 1 Januar und das
auch insbesondere was die bessere
Förderung angeht was wir im Mietrecht
verbess ern ich bin sicher Werner
darüber wird dann noch im Detail darauf
eingehen was die kommunale wärmeplanung
angeht und vor allen Dingen wie wir es
schaffen die Klimaziele zu erreichen
eine große Auswahl an Technologien wird
zur Verfügung stehen die wärmeplanung
hilft den Menschen und den Unternehmen
kluge Entscheidungen zu treffen wir
haben die Entscheidungszeit entsprechend
angepasst und die Menschen bekommen eine
sehr gute Beratung um sich für
zu entscheiden insofern gedanklich all
denjenigen die jetzt auch schon den
Sommer und die nächsten Monate nutzen
hier ein Beitrag für Klimaschutz und
Versorgungssicherheit zu leisten
herzlichen Dank
für Herr Linden hat hier natürlich noch
einmal den Klimaschutz angesprochen aber
auch der nächste Redner engagiert sich
schon lange für Klimapolitik Klimaschutz
Lukas Köhler auf aus der FDP-Fraktion er
ist auch stellvertretender
Fraktionsvorsitzender
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident meine sehr
verehrten Damen und Herren die Union
eigentlich freue ich mich über die
Debatte weil das was sie hier gerade
gemacht haben zeigt vor allen Dingen
eine Sache sie haben nur noch Kritik in
der Form und das finde ich gut es ist
schön dass Sie das Gesetz nicht mehr in
der Sache kritisieren dass sie sich hier
nicht hinstellen und sagen das sind
unsere Vorschläge das sind die Punkte
sondern es geht ihnen um Kritik in der
Form und das ist auch das was das
Bundesverfassungsgericht in seiner
Entscheidung festgestellt hat dass die
Änderungsanträge die wir hier machen die
wir hier vorliegen dieses Gesetz zu 180
Grad ändern und drehen und das ist eine
Tragweite hat und eine breite in der
Änderung die gut ist und das ist genau
das was wir in der ersten Lesung in der
debat sich angekündigt haben dass wir
als Parlament und selbstbewusst
hinsetzen und aus diesem Gesetz ein
gutes Gesetz machen dass die Menschen
dass die Bürgerinnen und Bürger in
Deutschland nicht alleine lassen das
dafür sorgt dass wir Heizung und
Heizungseinbau in Deutschland vernünftig
organisieren das vor allen Dingen der
Staat als etwas sagen muss wie es geht
über die kommunale wärmeplanung und das
dann Bürgerinnen und Bürger sich
daraufhin frei entscheiden können dass
keine Heizung rausgerissen werden müssen
wie hier fälschlich behauptet wird und
dass wir nicht in das Eigentum der
Menschen eingreifen das legt dieser
Gesetzesentwurf in dieser Form wie wir
ihn beschließen werden vor und das ist
das was wir geändert haben das ist der
Plan ein technologieoffenes Gesetz das
dafür sorgt dass wir wirkliche
Veränderungen in Deutschland schaffen
ohne Menschen zu überfordern das ist es
was ich eigentlich von ihnen in der
Debatte hören will nämlich dass das und
wie das bei ihnen gehen soll das sind
die Herausforderungen für den
wichtigsten
sich hier hinstellen und als eine der
großen Kritikpunkte die Sitzordnung im
Deutschen Bundestag anbringen finde ich
ein bisschen traurig wir haben in
Deutschland eine riesen Debatte laufen
darüber wie die Zukunft dieses Land geht
wir haben eine riesen Debatte darüber
wie Fortschritt
ausgestaltet werden soll darüber dass
das auch mal zu Streit kommt dass da
auch mal Debatten laufen ist das ist
völlig klar und völlig
aber die Sitzordnung des Deutschen
Bundestages meiner Meinung
nachträglichkeit Zwischenfrage des
Kollegen Fraktion
Herr Dobrindt dass sie die zweite dritte
Lesung die Beratung hier im Bundestag
nicht als Debatte empfinden zeigt viel
über das Verständnis dieses Parlaments
das was wir hier tun ist eine Debatte
wir ringen hier um die Sache wir reden
hier darüber mit welchen Argumenten
eingesetzt besser gemacht wird das ist
ein Parlament hier wird gestritten und
sie behaupten dass es keine Beratung
mehr zu dem Gesetz gibt natürlich was
machen wir denn hier wir diskutieren
hier das den ganzen Tag reden wir
darüber wie dieses Land vorangebracht
werden muss und ja die Union ist
konstruktiv dass eine konstruktive
Opposition die hier dabei mitmischt wie
in den Debatten Dinge besser werden
können das können sich alle Opposition
von sich behaupten das stimmt sie sind
das und sie machen hier mit aber das wir
hier beraten ist genau der
parlamentarische Weg wie wir Gesetze
abschließen ich bin ein bisschen
überrascht darüber wie Sie damit um und
in der Sache ist dieses Gesetz auf einem
wirklich guten Weg und ich bin mir
sicher dass in der zweiten und dritten
lesen wir dafür sorgen werden dass
dieses gute jetzt dann auch durchgeht
warum weil wir dafür sorgen dass Holz
auch im Neubau eine erfüllungsoption ist
weil wir dafür sorgen dass Heizungen in
Zukunft klimaneutral werden auch
Gasheizung wenn sie mit Wasserstoff oder
Biomethan betrieben werden weil wir alle
Optionen für die Menschen darlegen weil
wir dafür sorgen dass Deutschland
vorankommt beim Klimaschutz und
gleichzeitig die Bürgerinnen und Bürger
sich ihren heizungsausbau sehr Umbau
selber wählen können das sind die
Herausforderungen für die wir gestellt
wurden und das sind die
Herausforderungen die wir lösen das ist
das was Fortschritt bedeutet das Ringen
um die Sache um dann eine gute Lösung
vorzulegen und sie erwarte mir von der
Union dass sie sich in der Sache zu den
Dingen äußern weil was ist denn ihre
Frage was ist denn ihre Lösung was sind
denn die Punkte und Probleme die sie
hier vorliegt was ist denn ihre Kritik
an dem Gesetz in der Sache das hätte ich
mir von ihnen erwartet das ist darum
geht und nicht Umformung
und ich hätte mich auch darüber gefreut
ehrlicherweise wenn wir noch ein paar
Sachen zur Form in Europa und dem was da
kommt gehört hätten was ihre
kommissionspräsidentin da gerade
vorliegt weil wir brauchen uns hier im
Deutschen Bundestag nicht über ein
Gebäude Energiegesetz unterhalten wenn
wir in Europa auf einmal ab 2027
Gasheizung verbieten wir brauchen uns
hier nicht über ein Gebäude
Energiegesetz unterhalten wenn wir
sanierungspflichten noch ein Löcher auf
europäischer Ebene beschließen ich hätte
mir von Ihnen erwartet dass hier mal was
dazu kommt ich hätte mir von Ihnen
erwartet dass sie jemand in der Sache
auch darüber reden wie sie diesen
Prozess zwischen Europa und Deutschland
verbinden wollen das hätte ich mir von
ihnen erwartet und da ist nichts
gekommen und das ist doch das Problem
die Leute die BürgerInnen in Deutschland
erwarten von uns Antworten und ja und
das muss man auch selbstkritisch sagen
wir haben Prozesse die zum Teil oft
schnell gehen und ja ich finde auch dass
wir gemeinsam mit der Opposition mit der
konstruktiven Opposition an den Dingen
arbeiten müssen das voranzubringen weil
auch das bedeutet die Debatte um
Fortschritt auch das Ringen um die
richtige Sache und deswegen können wir
besser werden und ich erwarte auch von
uns selber auch von uns als
Ampel-Koalition auch von meiner Fraktion
auch von mir selber dass wir besser in
dieser Sache werden aber dass wir ein
gutes Gesetz vorlegen das haben wir an
dieser Stelle getan und da bin ich sehr
stolz drauf vielen Dank
der Bundestag diskutiert über den
Beschluss des
Bundesverfassungsgerichts zum Gebäude
Energiegesetz und das ist dieses Urteil
überhaupt gab das verdanken die
Abgeordneten dem nächsten Redner Thomas
Heilmann aus der Unionsfraktion hatte
nämlich geklagt dass hier die Rechte der
Abgeordneten nicht wie er möchte
berücksichtigt wurden und das dann die
Richter ähnlich
herr Präsident meine Damen und Herren
liebe Kollege Köhler ich wollte hier
etwas überparteiliches zum Schluss sagen
aber Einsatz muss ich Ihnen schon sagen
dass sie allen ernst ist die verkorkste
Reihenfolge ihres Gesetzgebungsverfahren
gut heißen hier und sagen wir hätten
dazu keine abweichenden Äußerungen getan
das ist schlicht nicht weit wie diese
sitzen nicht im Ausschuss für Klima
Energie da habe ich das ja ausführlich
gesagt wird aber gerne etwas
ich würde gerne etwas zum Schluss der
Debatte oder fast zum Schluss der
Debatte sagen der mir sehr sehr
wichtig ist
wir alle hier aus allen Fraktionen haben
uns so geäußert dass wir über die
Verfahren unglücklich sind und absolut
zugegeben unglücklich auch schon in der
letzten Legislatur
und wenn wir das alle so sehen dann
müssen wir wir frei gewählten
Abgeordneten doch etwas tun und ich
finde nicht dass wir auf Karlsruhe
warten müssen alle haben hier irgendwie
Gnade Hauptsache Entscheidung hat wollen
wir wirklich das Karlsruhe uns
Vorschriften macht die unsere
Geschäftsordnung zu lauten hat und wie
sie auszulegen ist ich glaube wir
brauchen gemeinsame Vorschriften und ich
will Ihnen dazu noch etwas sagen was
mich in der Debatte im Tonfall oder in
der
Zwischentönen gestört hat
es wurde mehrfach insbesondere von ihnen
Forscher gesagt wir brauchen
Flexibilität
im Verfahren das ist natürlich nicht
ganz unrechtlich aber wir in diesem
Parlament machen den Bürgerinnen und
Bürgern die hier auf der Tribüne sitzen
und draußen laufend Vorschriften sehr
viele Vorschriften und oft auch zu viele
Vorschriften und wir sagen dann wir
wollen uns selber aber keine einengenden
Vorschriften machen weil wir die
notwendige Flexibilität brauchen da wäre
wenn wir selber Herr des Verfahrens sind
können wir für die notwendige
Flexibilität sorgen und haben wir in der
corona-krise und in der Krise um den
schrecklichen Ukraine Krieg auch
dargestellt deswegen ist es aus meiner
Sicht in der Tat klug wenn wir jetzt
alle in die Sommerpause gehen aber es
wäre dann eben vor allen Dingen wichtig
dass wir uns selbst beschränken als
Parlament in unserem Tempo wir brauchen
einen Tempolimit auch für dieses
Parlament insbesondere für die
Regelfälle weil wir in dieser Art und
Weise nicht weitermachen können und das
haben wir so viele so viele Abgeordnete
auf der ampelfraktion auf der links
verteilt nicht nur aus meiner Fraktion
gesagt dass sie das doch eigentlich auch
so sehen es haben alle anzuhören und
gesagt in den letzten Anhörungen es
haben alle Medien gesagt wir müssen doch
diesen Weckruf hören und wenn man einen
Weckruf hört dann muss man aufstehen und
etwas tun und nicht liegen bleiben
und deswegen kann ich nur daran
appellieren dass wir diese doch
vorhandene Gemeinsamkeiten nutzen und
uns jetzt Dinge
engere
verbindlichere Vorschriften machen wie
die zeitlichen Abläufe bei uns sein
können und können nicht sagen das gibt
so viele Einzelfall Dinge das können wir
nicht regeln natürlich muss es Ausnahmen
geben das muss ich auch bei vielen
anderen Vorschriften geben das werden
wir doch hinkriegen wenn wir das
wirklich wollen und deswegen ist das
mein abschließende Appell vor der
Sommerpause in jedem Problem liegt doch
auch eine Chance und natürlich ist das
jetzt ein Problem für die Ampel aber es
ist auch die Aufgabe der Opposition aber
wenn es da eben ein Problem gibt dann
lassen Sie uns diese Chance nutzen und
gemeinsam für strengere Regeln
Verfahrensregeln in diesem Parlament
selber sorgen und nicht erst auf
Karlsruhe haben vielen Dank
vielen Dank Thomas Heilmann war das für
die Unionsfraktion und damit kommen wir
zum letzten Redner in dieser Debatte aus
der SPD-Fraktion spricht nun Bernhard da
drauf der Sprecher für Wohnstadt
Entwicklung Bauwesen und Kommunen
Präsident liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
Herr Merz ich wollte sie gerade
ansprechen aber jetzt verlassen sie
leider den Saal das ist schade
sie möchten nämlich ganz gerne dass wir
über die politische Kultur in diesem
Haus reden und über die Art und Weise
wie wir uns auseinandersetzen und ich
finde das gut dass sie das appellieren
und dann habe ich aber auch die bitte
daran und darauf komme ich in meiner
Rede noch zurück dass sie vor Sieges
geheult sozusagen im Außenbereich in
sozialen Medien vor Verunsicherung und
Verängstigung der Bevölkerung dem auch
Einhalt gebieten weil das gehört auch
zur politischen Kultur der sich dann
nicht erziehen
wir reden ja wir reden ja heute über wir
reden ja heute nicht in erster Linie
über das Gebäude Energiegesetz sondern
wir reden über den Beschluss des
Bundesverfassungsgerichts aber ich will
trotzdem ein bisschen etwas sagen zum
Inhalt dieses Gebäude Energiegesetzes
und ich will Ihnen auch sagen warum wir
eigentlich dieses GEW zum jetzigen
Zeitpunkt modernisieren glauben Sie etwa
wir hätten die Haltung die Bürgerinnen
und Bürger ärgern zu wollen nein das tun
wir nicht nein wir haben eine politische
Haltung wir haben eine politische
Haltung die sich fundamental von ihrem
gegründe sozusagen unterscheidet wir
haben nämlich uns verpflichtet uns dem
Klimaschutz zu stellen und das aus einer
zutiefst moralischen Verantwortung
heraus Bewahrung der Schöpfung Sicherung
unserer Lebensgrundlagen Verantwortung
gegenüber nachfolgenden Generationen und
wenn man sich solchen Zielen
verpflichtet gegenüber dann ist man zum
Handeln verpflichtet und nicht zum
unterlassen
wenn ich das sagen darf wir kommen ja
beide aus Nordrhein-Westfalen deswegen
kennen Sie hier diesen rheinischen
Spruch die lange Bank ist es deutlich
und achten Sie darauf dass Sie nicht
darauf Platz nehmen achten Sie darauf
wir werden für dieses Gesetz werben für
eine klimagerechte wärmewende während
der Dobrindt Haltungsnoten verteilt
Haltungsnoten verteilt zum Beispiel in
den letzten
arroganzampel und respektloser Umgang
mit dem Parlament mit einem für sie
übrigens ungünstigen Foto das Twittern
sie das und aus ihren Reihen kommt der
Verkehrsminister für den wir gerade eine
Schadensersatzzahlung in Höhe von 247
Millionen machen müssen aufgrund von
Ignoranz und Arroganz ist nämlich die
Schwester der Arroganz damit sie es nur
wissen
und weil ich ja sehe dass sie hier in
der ersten Reihe sitzen kann ich Ihnen
nur sagen kann ich Ihnen nur sagen an
anderer Stelle werden Sie einer der
Pharisäer die als erste aus dem Tempel
gejagt wurden da können Sie sich darauf
verlassen
ich sage Ihnen diese bei dieser Debatte
werden Ihnen perspektivisch die
inhaltlich interessierten Menschen nicht
folgen aber es werden ihnen diejenigen
Folgen deren Jubel sie vermeintlich oder
Herr Merzig glaube es ihnen tatsächlich
nicht wollen so wie es auch Herr
Heilmann nicht will aber er kann sich
bei seinem Antrag an das
Bundesverfassungsgericht ruhig dagegen
verwahren dass sich die AFD daran hängt
aber er kann es nicht verhindern leider
kann er es nicht verhindern es ist geht
ihm wieder Zauberlehrling der die
Geister die eriften und nicht mehr los
wird bedenken sie das bei ihren
Diskussionen wie sie damit umgehen
aber wir werden auch die
Verfahrensfragen nicht verändern wir
werden die nicht vernachlässigen meine
Kolleginnen meine Kollegin Nina Scheer
hat darauf hingewiesen dass das Gesetz
im Grunde genommen seit dem April schon
im parlamentarischen Verfahren gegeben
hat das ist immer wieder Anregungen zum
Gesetzentwurf der Bundesregierung
gegeben hat das ist viele Veränderungen
gegeben hat aber es gibt keinen
Eigentumsrecht auf die Wahrheit und es
ist nicht erst dann wahr wenn es ihre
Akzeptanz finden so ist das nicht
es hat zwei parlamentarische Anhörungen
gegeben ich frag mal die Union wann
haben Sie jemals in einem Verfahren 22
parlamentarische Anhörung beantragt nee
haben sie nicht gemacht nein nein haben
sie nicht gemacht das ist schlicht oder
greifen so und die Welt hat zu dieser
zweiten Anhörung gesagt zu den
Stellungnahmen der Sachverständigen es
wäre eine überwiegend sehr positive
Reaktion gewesen auf den neuen auf den
veränderten Entwurf ja so war das
der doofen beklagt die öffentliche
Debatte meine Güte dieses Gesetz ist
doch so häufig in Permanenz in der
Öffentlichkeit debattiert worden und es
hat fundamentale Veränderungen gegeben
gerade im Verhältnis zu kommunalen
wärmeplanung als Voraussetzung als
Voraussetzung jetzt kommen wir zu ihren
Änderungsvorschlägen in ihrem Antrag
das geht relativ schnell
sie fordern nämlich einen Neustart beim
gebäudech Energiegesetz die meinen aber
eigentlich nur ein weiter so sie
sprechen sich darin aus gegen eine
Regulierung für einen heizungsaustausch
den haben wir aber schon im GEW drin
stehen und das haben sie mit beschlossen
das wollen sie jetzt alles gar nicht
mehr und dann kommen Sie mit der
kommunalen wärmeplanung die doch bis zur
Koalitionsvereinbarung dieser
Ampelkoalition für sie ein Fremdwort
gewesen ist sie wusste noch gar nicht
was das ist würde gerne noch ein
bisschen ausführlicher darauf eingehen
aber ich muss jetzt gucken
und jetzt mal oder Einbeziehung von
Sachverständigen Transparenz für die
Öffentlichkeit es ist doch kein kein
einziges Gesetz so auf den Nachrichten
und den Öffentlichkeit gewesen wie
dieses zwei Anhörung ich habe das gesagt
und jetzt will ich etwas zum
Beratungsverfahren sagen und jetzt ist
wichtig Herr März dass sie auch zuhören
weil ich etwas sage jetzt was ich auch
nicht für uns schon für uns auch nicht
charmant ist aber ich will es ihnen
sagen an dieser Stelle weil sie ja in
ihrer Rede von der Einmaligkeit
gesprochen haben der Vorgänge die hier
passiert deswegen will ich Ihnen mal
nicht aus der Pandemie Zeit nehmen das
war eine besondere Situation
zugegebenermaßen ich nenne ihn
vergleichbar die Beratungen zum EEG vom
8 juli 2016 ist eine ähnlich wichtige
Angelegenheit gewesen dort Beklagte die
von mir sehr geschätzte Kollegin Britta
Hassmann das Verfahren und verwies auf
deshalb halten 412 seitenänderungen die
in einer Synopse den Mitgliedern des
Ausschusses um 9:41 Uhr vorgelegt worden
sind während die Sitzung um 10 Uhr
begangen wir haben das bedauert
wir haben das bedauert und der
Parlamentarische Geschäftsführer der
Unionsfraktion Michael große Brömer hat
etwas gesagt was ich bemerkenswert finde
Zitat wir müssen den Bürgerinnen und
Bürgern und den Unternehmen in
Deutschland Rechtssicherheit geben damit
Sie wissen ob sie noch investieren
sollen und wie es mit den erneuerbaren
Energien weitergeht das ist wahrhafte
Verantwortung einer Regierung das war
die Reaktion wahrhafte Regeln die
Fähigkeit eines Abgeordneten sich mit
der Materie zu beschäftigen auch darauf
hatte er eine Antwort da sagte er zu
Frau Hasselmann Zitat diese Kollegen die
ihrer Fraktion prüfen die Unterlagen mit
Sicherheit genauso wie wir wie sie und
wenn diesem Kollegen zu der Auffassung
gelangen sie können entscheiden dann ist
das ihre Entscheidung da brauche ich von
ihnen keine Belehrungen wir sind keine
schlechteren Parlamentarier als sie und
deswegen wird dieser Tagesordnungspunkt
nicht abgesetzt sondern sinnvollerweise
heute debattiert und übrigens auch
beschlossen das ist die Vorhang das ist
die Herangehensweise wenn sie in der
Mehrheit sind und deswegen sage ich
Ihnen noch mal eindeutig damit muss man
umgehen das ist die moralische
Rechtfertigung wenn man über politische
Kultur über die über den Umgang von
Verfahren in einem Parlament redet daher
gucken Sie gespannt das ist für sie
Neuland ich weiß es nicht ich weiß es
wohl ich schließe jetzt ich schließe
jetzt der Präsident und bedanke mich
dafür dass sie mir so lange das Wort
gegeben herzlichen Dank
das war dann die Debatte zum Beschluss
des Bundesverfassungsgerichts zum
Gebäude Energiegesetz eigentlich sollte
das heizungsgesetz ja heute
verabschiedet werden weil es aber eben
eine Klage vor dem
Bundesverfassungsgerichts gab und eben
ein entsprechendes Urteil muss sich die
Koalition und vertagen und gerade die
Grünen wollten das ja sehr gern eben
noch vor der Sommerpause durchbringen
das hat nicht geklappt aber auf der
neuen Tagesordnung steht auch schon das
Gebäude Energiegesetz drauf momentan
heißt es am 8 september werden sich die
Abgeordneten wieder damit dann
beschäftigen das ist in der Woche von
der haushaltswoche deswegen wird dieser
Tagesordnungspunkt momentan als Letzter
aufgeführt am Freitag wir werden sehen
in wie weit sich die Tagesordnung dort
eventuell noch verschieben wird